hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live heute ist europa-tag er steht für
Frieden und Freiheit auf unserem
Kontinent und für eine politische
Zusammenarbeit die einen Krieg auf
diesem Kontinent bei uns eigentlich
unmöglich machen sollte eigentlich denn
wie wir alle wissen ist dass seit
letztem Jahr nicht mehr der Fall seit
dem russischen Angriff Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine und gleichzeitig feiert
Russland heute auch ein historischen Tag
sein Sieg über Nazi Deutschland vor 78
Jahren sie feiern ein Ende des Krieges
den Krieg Deutschlands und führen
parallel dazu einen eigenen ihren Krieg
in der Ukraine das beschäftigt uns heute
und wir wollen mit euch zum einen Live
nach Moskau schauen da will Putin heute
Stärke demonstrieren und eine Rede
halten eine traditionelle Militärparade
wird stattfinden und wir wollen mit euch
natürlich auch diese Rede analysieren
schauen was da erwartet wird was dort
verkünde genannt wird und wir schauen
außerdem aber auch live in die Ukraine
denn dort ist Ursula von der Leyen
eu-kommissionspräsidentin in Kiew
eingetroffen dass alles heute Thema bei
uns stellt gerne live dazu Fragen im
Stream ich versuche so viele wie möglich
davon mit rein zu nehmen in den Stream
zu beantworten denn wir haben uns ein
Experten eingeladen bei uns ist jetzt
Militär und Russland Experte Nico lange
schönen guten Morgen Herr Lange guten
Morgen Herr Lange es wird natürlich
erwartet dass Putin also auch bei so
einer Rede sich zum ukrainekrieg jetzt
äußert was muss man da befürchten muss
man befürchten dass er neue
Eskalationsstufen ankündigt was vermuten
sie
hat ja schon länger das Problem dass er
nicht mehr eskalieren kann und es ist
natürlich auch so dass jetzt am 9 mai
eigentlich nichts vorzuweisen hat außer
großen Verlusten er hat nichts erreicht
militärisch insofern würde ich erwarten
dass es ein Ritual gibt aus den
Zeremonien die eben am 9 mai stattfinden
und wo ist ein großes Problem wäre dann
Putin die eben nicht stattfinden lässt
und er wird seine historischen
Erzählungen versuchen zu wiederholen wo
er versucht diesen Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg der Sowjetunion
gleichzusetzen mit dem Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine das natürlich Unsinn
aber das wird er versuchen
das werden wir auf jeden Fall im
Nachgang natürlich noch mal eingehend
besprechen analysieren was auch ein
Thema sein wird für uns heute gestern
gab es wieder erneut heftige russische
Luftangriffe in der Ukraine zwei Drittel
des Landes waren davon betroffen
Luftalarm über Stunden für die Menschen
dort könnte das aber auch heute also am
Tag noch mal geplant sein in derselben
Intensität oder noch intensiver was hat
die Ukraine zu befürchten heute
die Luftangriffe sind ja sehr intensiv
geworden in den letzten Tagen und auf
Kiew war es ja das erste Mal seit über
50 Tagen das ist wieder losging mir
scheint so traurig das ist Putin muss
Bilder produzieren für zu Hause fürs
Fernsehen in Russland wo er Stärke zeigt
weil eben zum Beispiel bachmut oder auch
die FK oder andere Städte nicht erobert
worden sind und es gibt nichts zu feiern
deswegen jetzt also Luftangriffe um
Stärke zu demonstrieren besonders
traurig ist das für die Städte die in
der Nähe der Front sind also Person
weil dort mit sehr sehr vielen
umfunktionierten Raketen des Typs S300
immer wieder in die Gebäude geschossen
wird und da gibt es immer wieder Tote
und Verletzte die in nachts im Schlaf
getroffen werden also das ist
furchtbarer Terror der der ausgeübt wird
wir sprechen gleich mit ihnen weiter
schauen jetzt aber kurz live nach Moskau
zu meiner Kollegen Korrespondentin für
Bega ist jetzt bei uns schön guten
guten Morgen für du hast schon so so
viele Reden Putins gehört und jetzt
natürlich deine Einschätzung zu heute
was erwartest du von dieser Rede heute
an diesem traditionellen Tag der
Militärparade was ist dazu erwarten
heute von Putin
also vielleicht erstmal was ich eher
nicht erwarte das ist eine neue
mobilisierungswelle die er verkünden
wird denn es ist das wäre eine sehr
unpopuläre Maßnahme und es ist so dass
Vladimir Putin solche Verkündung dann
normalerweise lieber seinen Ministern
oder Untergebenen überlässt es gibt
außerdem Anzeichen dafür dass derzeit
versucht wird abseits der Blicke der
Öffentlichkeit Soldaten für diesen Krieg
in der Ukraine zu gewinnen z.B wird wohl
verstärkt das sind jetzt britische
Geheimdienst Informationen verstärkt in
Moscheen und unter zentral asiatischen
Einwanderern hier in Russland rekrutiert
den Menschen wird dann eine schnelle
Einbürgerung und viel Geld versprochen
was ich von dieser Rede erwartet das ist
zum einen dass Vladimir Putin wieder
einmal versuchen wird eben einen
rhetorischen Bogen zu spannen zwischen
dem historischen Sieg der Sowjet Armee
über die Nationalsozialismus und den
Kämpfen heute in der Ukraine und auch
wahrscheinlich ist es dass wir neue
Drogen oder wiederholte Drogen gegen den
besten zu hören bekommen
was er auch nicht ganz uninteressant ist
letzte Woche war es unruhig in Moskau es
gab einen Drohnenangriff in Moskau der
kremme hatte verkündet dass zwei Drohnen
über dem russischen Regierungssitz
abgeschossen wurden zerstört worden sind
und laut russischen Angaben war das ein
Angriff der Ukraine die Ukraine die
streitet das ab aber da war es also
unruhig letzte Woche wie sehr
beeinflusst das denn jetzt die
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen für diesen
historischen Tag heute und all das was
da geplant ist
also nach diesem Drohnenangriff von dem
wir immer noch nicht genau wissen wer
dahinter gesteckt hat von wem er ausging
auf jeden Fall war danach hier durchaus
eine gewisse Nervosität zu spüren es
wurde dann ja zum Beispiel erstmal
verboten Drohnen überhaupt steigen zu
lassen das gilt natürlich auch für heute
und die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen rund um die
Parade die wurden enorm verschärft schon
in den letzten Tagen kam es zu massiven
Störungen von GPS-Signalen auch von den
Mobilfunknetzen die Straßen sind viel
weiträumiger abgesperrt als ich das aus
den letzten Jahren kenne heute Morgen
auf dem Weg zur Arbeit konnte ich sehen
dass Moskau quasi ausgestorben ist es
gibt also kaum Fußgänger oder Autos die
unterwegs sind auch entlang der
paradenstrecke wo sind normalerweise
sich Leute sammeln um eben die Waffen an
ihn an sich vorbei Rollen zu sehen da
saß relativ leer aus andere Städte haben
die Militärparaden ja ganz abgesagt das
konnte sich bei die mir Putin sicherlich
nicht leisten aber es gab noch eine
weitere Sache die ähm gestern dann
aufploppt und zwar sah es lange Zeit so
aus als würde es nur einen
internationalen Gast bei dieser Parade
geben nämlich den kirgisischen
Präsidenten gestern kamen dann am
Nachmittag plötzlich Zusagen aus ganz
Zentralasien auch der armenische
Regierungschef wird auf der Tribüne sein
und das wirkt doch ganz so als habe der
Kreml in letzter Minute alles getan um
sozusagen dafür zu sorgen dass Wladimir
Putin eben heute nicht alleine da steht
und die Bilder zu produzieren dass er
Verbündete hat die an seiner Seite
stehen ein Schätzungen live aus Moskau
von für begab vielen Dank
ich muss kurz Husten Entschuldigung
also jetzt geht es aber wieder ich schau
mal kurz in den Chat nach Fragen von
euch hier gibt es zum Beispiel die Frage
von Melanie tut die sich fragt sind das
links aktuelle Bilder oder sind die vom
letzten Jahr das sind aktuelle Bilder
und die bei euch zeigen denn wir warten
ja live mit euch auf die Rede von
Präsident Putin und da ist die Parade
schon im Gang wir wollen jetzt aber noch
ganz kurz erstmal auf die Lage in der
Ukraine schauen denn wir haben es eben
gerade auch gehört es gibt zum einen in
Russland Sorge vor Angriffen im eigenen
Land es gibt aber auch hohe Verluste die
Russland in der Ukraine einfährt und für
Putin läuft das aktuell nicht ganz so
wie geplant und wir schauen zusammen
rein in einen Beitrag von Tim Romberg
es war wieder ein langer Kriegstag in
der Ukraine der Tag vor den russischen
siegesparaden an vielen Orten gingen
Raketen nieder griffen Drohnen die
ukrainische Infrastruktur an
Beschuss meldeten zahlreiche große
Städte im ganzen Land wieder habe es tot
und Verletzte gegeben und den bachmut
der Front statt der letzten Monate
Häuserblocks nur noch Grippe laut
Ukraine setzte Russland Phosphorbomben
ein
und doch kein Durchbruch für Russlands
Präsidenten seine Truppen kommen kaum
weiter und Ärger gibt es obendrein vor
einigen Tagen schimpft der Chef der
Wagner Söldner auf das
Verteidigungsministerium
will mehr Munition und Brot mit Rückzug
aus bachmut
auch auf der von Russland besetzten Krim
läuft es nicht so gut ein Treibstoff
Lager brennt Sabotage Akte wie diese
häufen sich die Ukraine steht
möglicherweise kurz vor ihrer
angekündigten Gegend offensiv die
schlechten Nachrichten erreichen Moskau
sogar direkt in Form zweier Drohnen die
kürzlich über dem kremme abgeschossen
wurden eine Warnung eine Inszenierung
unklar aber ein Zeichen dass der Krieg
seine Fühler bis nach Moskau ausstreckt
bei uns jetzt wieder Russland und
Militärexperte Nico lange Herr Lange es
gibt hier erste Fragen im Chat und zwar
möchte Marple Pavel bei Youtube wissen
gibt es denn neue Infos zu den Drohnen
wir haben gerade darüber gesprochen und
es auch im Beitrag gesehen also
Drohnenangriff letzte Woche in Moskau
gibt es dazu neue Infos denn sie
schreibt oder er schreibt noch weiter in
den ersten Tagen war ja nicht klar wer
dahinter steckt
das ist weiterhin nicht klar wer diese
Drohnen gestartet hat ist ja auch gar
nicht klar wo sie gestartet wurden kann
er auch sein dass die in Moskau oder
Nähe von Moskau gestartet wurden oder
sie sind eben den ganzen Weg aus der
Ukraine geflogen weiß man zu diesem
Zeitpunkt nicht vor allen Dingen hat
aber Russland in keiner Weise klar
gemacht warum sie eigentlich diese
Drohnen sofort der Ukraine zugeordnet
haben dafür gibt es keine Belege ja
nicht mal Informationen darüber was nun
die Faktoren waren dazu beigetragen
haben also es ist da weiter alles unklar
aber insgesamt scheint es auch so zu
sein dass Russland nicht mehr so viel
über diese drum sprechen möchte weil es
eben unheimlich peinlich war Drohnen auf
dem Dach im Kreml zu sehen
und jetzt sehen wir auch gerade wieder
neben ihnen Bilder ganz aktuell von der
Parade ich habe es angesprochen das sind
Bilder von heute die Wetter sehen das
ist eine ganz schöne Inszenierung dazu
fragt sich Johannes bei Youtube lässt
sich schon sagen ob mehr oder weniger
militärisches Gerät für die Parade
verwendet wird weil das was da natürlich
auch gezeigt wird die Panzer das soll
natürlich ja ein Zeichen von Stärke sein
zeigen wie stark Putins macht ist was
sagen sie dazu ist das eben mehr weniger
militärisches Gerät was möchte er zeigen
heute
traditionell finden am 9 mai Paraden ja
nicht nur in Moskau sondern in vielen
Städten in Russland statt und wir haben
in den letzten Tagen gesehen das sind
sehr vielen Städten in Russland diese
Paraden abgesagt worden sind und das
deutet ja darauf hin dass man gar nicht
genügend Technik hat oder dass man die
Technik anderswo braucht also in Moskau
wird man sicherlich Dinge zusammen
sammeln aber das hat ja auch eine
Tradition die bis in dieser Vitamin
zurückgeht dass das manchmal auch nur
Fassaden sind aber ein Moskau wird man
sicherlich versuchen stark auszusehen
aber dass man viele viele Paraden in
ganz Russland absagen musste ist schon
ein Zeichen dafür dass es nicht gut
läuft in diesem Krieg ein User von uns
äußert hier noch eine Vermutung
weil wenn sie Ambros fragt sich ich
nehme an Putin musste einige Paraden in
anderen Städten absagen so dass er genug
Truppen hat die in Moskau sind für die
Militärparade glauben sie das auch es
könnte eben auch mit der Truppenstärke
zusammenhängen das einfach zu wenig
Menschen aktuell in Russland verfügbar
sind für viele verschiedene Paraden
das ist glaube ich auf jeden Fall
zumal es ja nicht nur darum geht da
einmal hinzugehen und dann bei der
Parade sich aufzustellen diese Dinge
werden ja in für uns also
unverständlicherweise aber die werden ja
ständig vorgeübt also da muss man ganz
oft vorher antreten und marschieren und
sich hinstellen und und all diese
Übungen das kostet viel Zeit und bindet
viel Personal und deswegen hat Russland
glaube ich entschieden dass in viel
entsteht in diesem Jahr nicht zu machen
sondern nur in Moskau die Fassade
aufrecht zu erhalten das ist ja ein
Krieg der jetzt schon seit über einem
Jahr andauert ein Krieg von dem Putin
zunächst dachte er würde ihn im Nu
gewinnen müsste er da jetzt aber nicht
auch in so einer Rede wie heute
vielleicht mal ein Strategiewechsel
ankündigen kann man das von ihm erwarten
nein das kann man von ihm nicht erwarten
heute geht es darum den Schein der
Normalität zu wahren also es wäre ein
ganz großes Veränderung ein ganz großes
Signal wenn diese Parade nicht so
stattfinden würde wie üblich es gibt ja
da ein festgefügtes Ritual die Dinge
werden immer auf die gleiche Weise getan
und in Russland würde ja jeder der
verstehen will was im Kreml vor sich
geht oder ob es da Probleme gibt würde
jedes kleine Detail das abweicht von dem
wie das sonst gemacht wird
interpretieren und dort etwas hinein
interpretieren in der Frage wackelt
Putin gibt es da Konflikte und so weiter
also deswegen ist es ganz wichtig diese
Fassade aufrecht zu halten und alles so
durchzuführen als wäre nicht ich glaube
über die Wahrheit dieses Krieges wird
hier nicht gesprochen werden für all
jene die jetzt erst bei uns Einschalten
wir sehen gerade hier live Bilder von
der traditionellen militärparade zum
Ende des Krieges gegen Nazi Deutschland
in Russland wir warten mit euch
gemeinsam auf die Rede die Präsident
Putin dort halten wird werden sie im
Nachgang analysieren ich sehe jetzt auch
hier wir haben am Anfang schon drüber
gesprochen wollen das jetzt aber gerne
noch mal kurz aufgreifen eine Frage von
Christian bei Youtube der wissen möchte
was erwarten sie von Putin in seiner
Rede Herr Lange würden sie das für uns
noch mal beschreiben
ja es geht zum einen darum so zu tun als
wäre alles normal und deswegen die
Erzählung des Großen Vaterländischen
Krieges und des Sieges der Sowjetunion
weil die Rede beginnt wir schauen
gemeinsam rein und dann sprechen wir im
Nachgang weiter
[Musik]
Staatsbürger Russlands Liebe Veteranen
genossen Soldaten
Offiziere Generäle
Kämpfer sollten
Operation ich beglückwünsche Sie zum
dieser Feiertag zum Tag der Sieges
das ist ein Feiertag für unsere Väter
für unsere Vorfahren
das war eine ruhmreiche Generation für
unsere Heimat viele Opfer gab's und sie
haben die Menschheit vom Narzissmus von
Nationalsozialismus befreit heutzutage
stehen wir wieder am Scheideweg
es gibt wieder ein Krieg gegen unserer
Heimat aber wir stehen fest gegen den
internationalen Terrorismus wir werden
für die Sicherheit vom dornhaus
Bevölkerung kämpfen und für unsere
Sicherheit für uns Russland gibt es
keine nicht freundlich gestimmte Völker
Rede im Westen noch im Osten wie die
meisten Völker auf unserem Planeten
möchten wir unsere Zukunft friedlich und
stabil sehen wer denken dass jede
Ideologie der Überlegenheit ist ekelhaft
es verbrecherisch und bringt tot nicht
desto trotz gibt es Frieden vom Westen
von den westlichen globalistischen
Eliten sie meinen dass sie einzigartig
sind sie sehen Hass und Verfeindung sie
provozieren Konflikte
internationalisieren und sie treten
gegen Russland aus auf sie sind
russophob sie vernichten traditionelle
Werte die einen Menschen zu Menschen
machen und das machen sie damit sie
weiterhin
ihren Willen an die Völker diktieren
können ihre Regeln
und in Wirklichkeit ist das ein System
der Unterdrückung offenbar haben sie
vergessen
womit die Ansprüche von
Nationalsozialisten zu Ende gegangen
sind wer gegen diese übel gekämpft hat
wer für die Heimat gekämpft hat und das
Leben geopfert hat um die Völker der
Welt zu befreien wir sehen heutzutage
dass es in einigen Ländern man Wachen an
die sowjetischen Soldaten vernichtet
werden
Denkmäler an volksherren
das ist ein nazi-kult aufblüht das
Gedächtnis das Gedenken und Erinnerung
an die echten Helden will man verloren
dieses geboren dieses Verhalten ist auch
eine
Straftat ein
die ganz offensichtlich einen neuen
Kreuzzug gegen Russland vorbereitet
haben
sie haben Ihre Ziele und die sind nicht
neun die Ziele sind darin unser Land zu
vernichten auseinander zu halten die
Lehren des Zweiten Weltkrieges
durchzustreichen und das System von
globaler Sicherheit zu vernichten alle
souveränen
Entwicklungszentren im Keim zu ersticken
das hört zu einer tragöde genau darin
liegt der Grund für die Katastrophe
das Volk der Ukraine das folgende
Ukraine ist so geiselt geworden von
staatlichen
Umsturz und Geiseln von westlichen
Heeren
für uns in Russland ist das Gedenken und
der Erinnerung an die Kämpfer von damals
ist heilig wir denken auch an die
resistenzkämpfer die gegen den
Nationalsozialismus gekämpft haben die
Kämpfer von alliierten Armen von den USA
von Großbritannien von anderen Ländern
wir gedenken Heldentaten von
chinesischen Kämpfern im Kampf gegen den
japanischen Militarismus wir haben der
Erfahrung von Solidarität damals als
wäre gegen diese Bedrohung gekämpft
haben das ist für uns ein Fundament
heutzutage
damit diese Bewegung zum multipolaren
waldfahrt gewinnt die multipolare Welt
die auf
einheitliche unteilbare Sicherheit
basiert damit aller Länder sich frei
entwickeln können es ist sehr wichtig
dass es heutzutage in Moskau
Staatschefs von
Gemeinsamkeit
unabhängiger Staaten gibt das zeigt
davon dass sie an unsere Vorfahren
denken unsere Vorfahren haben gemeinsam
gekämpft gemeinsam gesetzt alle Völker
der Sowjetunion haben dazu beigetragen
dass es diesen gemeinsamen sieht wir
verneigen uns tief vor der heiligen
Erinnerung an die Opfer des Krieges
wir gedenken
und Freunden
ich möchte nun eine schweige Minute
einlegen
vielen Dank
sehr geehrter Staatsbürger Russland
es gibt Kämpfer die hier Schicksals
wichtig waren und sie waren für uns
immer heilig wer halten uns an unser
Versprechen fest
vor unseren Vorfahren und wir verstehen
welche Heldentaten sie vollbracht haben
wir sind stolz auf die Teilnehmer der
spezial-operation diejenigen die an der
Front kämpfen die die Verwundeten helfen
das ist heute die wichtigste Sache ihre
Kampfaufgabe sehr heißen heute die
Sicherheit unseres Landes fest und hoch
von ihnen ist es abhängig wie unsere
Staatlichkeit in Zukunft aussehen wird
und was mit unserem Volk passiert
sie kämpfen für Russland hinter ihnen
stehen ihre Familie ihre Kinder ihre
Freunde sie warten ich bin mir sicher
sie spüren ihre große Liebe das ganze
Land ist hinter ihnen und unterstützt
sie alle sind bereit zu helfen alle
beten für Sie
heute werden in jeder Familie in
Russland die Kämpfer des Großen
Vaterländischen Krieges geehrt es wird
ihnen gedacht und es werden
blumenkränzer niederlegt wir befinden
uns heutzutage auf dem Roten Platz
dieses Land erinnert sich an die Kämpfer
von Juri del garuke von
volksherr von Minion und passionski die
Paraden von
1941 und 1945
heute stehen hier auch die Teilnehmer
der Spezial Militäroperation das sind
Berufssoldaten da sind auch
wertpflichtige die immer Rahmen der
generalmobile machen kann berufen wurden
das sind auch Kämpfer aus Donuts von
Freiwilligen Bataillons auch von
Spezialeinheiten und anderen Ämtern ich
begrüße Sie lieber Freunde ich begrüße
alle die für Russland in den Schlachten
kämpft ich begrüße alle die heute diesen
Kampf führt in den Jahren des Großen
Vaterländischen Krieges haben unsere
Helden harten Vorfahren bewiesen unsere
Einigkeit ist das wichtigste und das
stärkste
unsere Liebe an die Heimat ist die
stärkste auf Russland auf unsere
heldenhafte Streitkräfte auf unseren
Sieg hurra
[Musik]
das war die Rede des russischen
Präsidenten Putins anlässlich des Sieges
über Nazi Deutschland die er aber auch
für seine Propaganda im eigenen Krieg
gegen die Ukraine genutzt hat wir fassen
kurz zusammen er sprach von einem Krieg
gegen seine Heimat gegen die russische
Heimat er sprach von internationalen
Terrorismus der ihn wieder fahre er
sprach aber auch von einer friedlichen
Zukunft die man sich vorstelle wir
werden das Ganze gleich einordnen ich
sehe Kommentare von Euch dazu auch schon
bei uns im Stream da wird Mengen
schreibt bei Youtube echt traurig wie
der Mann die Welt verdreht das wollen
wir jetzt besprechen bei uns ist wieder
Nico lange Russland und Militärexperte
der mit uns gemeinsam diese Rede gehört
hat schön dass sie wieder da sind hallo
Herr Lange
ähm hallo prima wir haben also von dem
russischen Präsidenten Putin gehört der
Westen der sehr Hass er provoziere
Konflikte und er sprach eben auch das
war auch interessant das habe ich mir
notiert davon dass die Ukraine zu einer
Geißel geworden sei von einem
staatlichen Umsturz man wundert sich
wovon spricht er da was meinte er damit
zunächst mal war das keine
beeindruckende Rede sie war sehr kurz es
war eigentlich nichts Neues und
offensichtlich gibt es nicht wirklich
was zu Feiern an diesem neunten mai das
hat man Putin angemerkt was den
staatlichen Umsturz betrifft ist es ja
die russische Erzählung dass die
Revolution der würde
2013/2014 und der Euro meine Damen der
ja sozusagen eine demokratische Bewegung
war in der Ukraine dass das so eine Art
Putsch gewesen wäre vom Besten
angeleitet das kennen wir als Erzählung
das ist aber falsch ist aber für Putins
Erzählung warum er letztlich angeblich
gezwungen war die Ukraine zu überfallen
sehr wichtig deswegen hat er das hier
auch wieder erwähnt
User Nils Pflüger schreibt bei Youtube
kommentiert also zu dieser Rede
interessant er meint also er Putin es
gibt auch keine Freunde im Osten
russland steht alleine würden sie das
auch so unterschreiben steht Russland
wirklich alleine und sieht gar keine
Freunde im Osten
das Putin relativ alleine steht hat man
ja gesehen also die Fernsehaufnahmen
haben ja versucht internationale Gäste
zu Filmen aber außer Herrn Lukaschenko
ist da eigentlich niemand mehr übrig
sind ja früher sogar Staats- und
Regierungschefs aus zum Beispiel unseren
Ländern zu diesen Paraden gefahren da
ist also keiner mehr habe auch aus China
niemanden gesehen der hochrangig war
bemerkenswert ist allerdings das Putin
in seinen Dank für die Kämpfer der
Sowjetarmee auch die Kämpfer der
chinesischen Armee gegen Japan
einbezogen hat also zumindest versucht
er China irgendwie einzubeziehen
wir haben noch mehr Fragen bei uns im
Stream ich schaue hier kurz rein und
zwar sehe ich hier
flüger noch mal eine Frage die hat hier
offensichtlich große Interesse das finde
ich gut er fragte sagte er general mobil
machen dachte es gab nur eine Teil mobil
machen können Sie uns da aufklären Herr
Lange
und hat über
generalprobung nicht gesprochen also da
gibt's nichts Neues jetzt aus dieser
Rede und für Sie auch sowieso gar nichts
unerwartetes ist unerwartet ist dabei
lässt sich das so zusammenfassen
ja das war das Ritual wurde aufrecht
erhalten Putin hat die Erwartung
historischen Verdrehungen gemacht wo er
kampfhaft versucht den
Verteidigungskrieg der Sowjetunion mit
dem Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
gleichzusetzen aber das ist eben nicht
das Gleiche das ist etwas völlig anderes
aber er muss das tun um irgendwie die
Russen bei der Stange zu halten und
ansonsten hat man das übliche Ritual
abgespult sprechen wir mal darüber wer
anwesend war denn auch dazu habe ich
eine Frage gesehen von Ferdinand orange
der sich fragte welche ausländischen
Staatsmänner sind angereist ich habe den
belarussischen Diktator Lukaschenko
gesehen war für sie da noch irgendjemand
der herausgestochen hat wo man dann also
sehen kann gut das ist ein Verbündeter
noch der Putin bleibt
bemerkenswert ist ja vor allen Dingen
wenn nicht kommt oder wer sich hier zu
kommen also früher war das Standard dass
die Nachbarn Russlands dorthin gekommen
sind und jetzt hieß es ja zum Anfang des
kommen nur die Gäste aus Belarus und
dann später kam noch Usbekistan und
andere Länder dazu aber sehr widerwillig
also das zeigt ja auch wie isoliert
putin ist und auch dass er an Einfluss
verliert in den Staaten die an der
russische Grenze liegen die sich ja sehr
stark auch mit der Ukraine
identifizieren und jedenfalls nicht
mitmachen wollen bei diesem
Angriffskrieg also das ist schon sehr
deutlich zu spüren es ist einsam für
Putin heute
Robert der User bei Youtube fragt sich
wie kann man mit diesem Mann irgendwann
mal wieder ernsthafte Politik machen ist
es überhaupt noch möglich oder kann es
eine Diplomatie zwischen Westen und
Russland nur ohne Putin geben was wäre
da ihre Einschätzung Herr Lange
zunächst einmal muss Putin gestoppt
werden Putin respektiert Stärke und
Macht Partnerschaft auf Augenhöhe das
gibt es für ihn nicht da ist er
sozialisiert als KGB-Agent und glaubt
man muss sich entweder unterordnen oder
man muss stärker sein und deswegen ist
jetzt wichtig dass es eine Demonstration
der Stärke gibt bei den Partnern der
Ukraine und Putin wird bereit sein
ernsthaft zu sprechen wenn er merkt dass
er militärisch nicht mehr weiterkommt in
der Ukraine er hat ja schon wenig
erreicht jetzt kommt die ukrainische
Gegend Offensive und diese Art von
systematische Unterstützung die wir
jetzt leisten für die Ukraine ist der
beste Weg um Putin dazu zu bringen dass
er anders spricht man wird sehen ob sich
in Russland gleichzeitig Dinge
entwickeln zum Beispiel in den macht
Zirkeln wo man der Auffassung ist dass
es ohne Putin besser weitergeht da haben
wir aber mittlerweile sehr wenig
Einblicke das sehr schwer zu verstehen
was dahinter den Mauern des Kreml vor
sich geht
sprechen wir aber noch mal um auch
Machtkämpfe die da vonstatten gehen also
der Wagner Chef brigoschin der sich da
auch immer mal wieder kritisch äußert
wir haben eine Frage dazu von Nils torbo
bei Youtube er fragt sich ist die Kritik
vom Wagner Chef wir haben es im Stück
wir erinnern uns vorhin von dem Romberg
auch gehört also ist die Kritik vom
wagner-chef eigentlich für voll zu
nehmen oder wollen Sie die Ukraine
ködern und unter dem Vorwand leichter
Beute in eine Falle laufen lassen was
ist da ihre Einschätzung auch zum
Verhältnis zwischen prigoshi und Putin
die Konflikte zwischen der wagnergruppe
und dem russischen
Verteidigungsministerium die sind echt
die gibt es schon länger da gibt es
immer wieder Auseinandersetzung
Pregarten ging es meiner Ansicht nach
darum jetzt vor dem 9 mai die
Schuldfrage zu klären also er hat ja
vollmund nicht angekündigt er mit seinen
Kämpfern ist viel stärker als die
russischen Streitkräfte und er wird
bachmut erobern und jetzt ist eben an
diesem 9 mai in diesem symbolisch
wichtigen Datum bachmut nicht
vollständig erobert worden und bringe es
also schon ein paar Tage vorher in die
Öffentlichkeit gesagt gegangen und hat
gesagt das liegt daran dass das
Verteidigungsministerium ihm nicht
genügend Munition gibt also Herr
scheuburg ist schuld daran ist ein
Problem dass da gespielt wird es gibt
eine ganze Reihe von Konflikten zwischen
unterschiedlichen Personen es gibt ja
auch immer lange leiden wer ist dichter
an Putin dran oder wer ist der
beliebteste beim Chef sozusagen das
kennt man auch aus der Vergangenheit aus
der Sowjetunion aus Russland
ist aber nicht so eine wichtige Figur
innerhalb Russlands wie das hier
manchmal scheint und insgesamt kann er
auch nicht viel wirklich selbstständig
agieren mit seiner wagnergruppe die
entscheidende Person ist Putin und wenn
Putin sagt mal Gruppe muss bleiben dann
würde zum Beispiel auch bleiben müssen
egal was er vorher gesagt hat es gibt
mehrere Kommentare die sich fragen wie
sich diese Rede auf die russische
Bevölkerung auswirkt ob die zufrieden
sein können mit einer Rede wie sie heute
gehört haben das ist da ihre
Einschätzung
ja den meisten Russen wird diese Rede
völlig egal sein das ist ein Ritual das
jedes Jahr durchgeführt wird und putin
war da und hat geredet dass das Signal
Signal das ganze hat stattgefunden das
war wichtig für Putin zu senden es gibt
eine Art von Normalität aber die Inhalte
dieser Rede nimmt glaube ich in Russland
keiner richtig für voll die Russen will
wissen sehr genau dass die sogenannte
Militäroperation gegen die Ukraine nicht
gut läuft sie spüren auch die
Auswirkungen von Sanktionen und von
wirtschaftlichen Problemen in Russland
aber in einer Diktatur wie der
russischen wo man für Demonstrationen im
weißen Blatt Papier in der Hand ins
Gefängnis gelangen kann da halten sie
dann lieber den Kopf unten aber wen er
so wird ja nun auch schon äh gibt es
glaube ich ein Russland Bewusstsein
dafür diese Propaganda nicht wirklich
ernst zu nehmen wir wollen gleich zum
Ende der Sendung noch mal live in die
Ukraine schalten deswegen an sie sehr
lange zum Schluss noch mal die Frage
zusammengefasst hier aus dem Stream da
fragt man sich wie kommt die ukrainische
gegen Offensive voran und gibt es nicht
eigentlich auch das Problem dass
Russland eben gar nicht mehr so viele
Marschflugkörper und Drohnen besetzt
also da gerne noch mal eine Einschätzung
von ihnen zum aktuellen Kriegsverlauf in
der Ukraine und den beiden Seiten wie
sie da stehen
die letzten Tage hat Russland die
Luftangriffe intensiviert ich glaube
auch um Bilder für das russische
Fernsehen zu produzieren und um stärker
zu demonstrieren aber es ist richtig was
der User schreibt dass Russland Probleme
hat mushrookörper nachzuproduzieren und
wenn man sich alleine anguckt das im
Herbst noch immer 60 70 80 manchmal
sogar 100 Raketen an einem Angriff
beteiligt waren und jetzt sind es 20 und
die Abstände zwischen den Angriffen
waren zuletzt über 50 Tage da kann
Russland also nicht mehr so stark
angreifen und die ukrainische
Luftverteidigung ist ja auch besser
geworden aber trotzdem ist das natürlich
ein großer Terror wenn immer wieder mit
Drohnen mit Raketen mitten in der Nacht
angegriffen wird die große Ziel hat
Russland nicht erreichen können nämlich
dass Energienetzwerk so zu zerstören
dass viele Ukraine den Winter
überfliehen müssen jetzt ist der
Frühling gekommen die Ukraine exportiert
sogar wieder Energie also insgesamt kann
man sagen die Ukraine hat diesen
russischen Luftangriffen getrotzt und
User Userin fragt sich glauben Sie dass
der Krieg 2023 noch entschieden werden
kann
wir sollten uns auf eine langfristige
und systematische Unterstützung der
Ukraine einstellen und auch diese
Gegenoffensive von der jetzt geredet
wird ist ja nicht ein großer Push und
dann ist alles vorbei sondern das wird
eine systematische Ablauf von mehreren
Operationen sein also wir sollten uns
ihr darauf einstellen dass das auch noch
bis ins Jahr 2024 dauern kann die
Gegenoffensive auf dem Südwestufer
desson hat von August bis November
gedauert für ein relativ überschaubares
Gebiet wenn Sie sich jetzt die Fläche da
angucken dann ist es glaube ich sehr
realistisch anzunehmen dass das noch
länger dauern wird das heißt auch wir
müssen systematisch und lange
unterstützen und nicht jetzt einfach nur
abwarten was passiert sagt
Militärexperte und Russland Experte Nico
lange vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns zu
Gast waren
sehr gerne
und wie angekündigt wollen wir jetzt
auch noch mal live in die Ukraine
schauen denn heute ist
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen in der Ukraine in Kiew sogar schon
angekommen und für uns live in Kiew ist
Tim Kröger der jetzt uns zugeschaltet
ist schön guten Morgen Tim hallo
guten Morgen Tim heute ist europa-tag
ich habe am Anfang der Sendung auch
gesagt das ist ein Grund auch ein Grund
warum Ursula von der Leyen heute also
nach Kiew gereist ist glaubst du das ist
aber auch ganz gezielt geplant als ein
Gegeneinander tief zu der Darstellung
der Militärparade der rede jetzt heute
in Russland
ja also man kann eigentlich gar keinen
anderen Eindruck haben dass dieser
Besuch heute von Ursula von der Leyen in
Kiew dieser Besuch bei Präsident
selenscan absolut symbolischer ist dass
das als klares Gegenprogramm zu dem
gedacht ist was da in Russland heute
stattfindet Ursula von der Leyen ist ja
heute morgen hier um ungefähr 7 Uhr mit
dem Zug angekommen wie schon auch fünf
Mal zuvor sie hat gesagt dass die
Ukraine fest in der Familie Europas
verankert ist da dass sie sich freut
wieder da zu sein es wird dann hier am
Vormittag ähm Gespräche geben zwischen
ihr und selensky da geht es unter
anderem auch noch mal um
munitionslieferung und dann wird sie
gegen Mittag ein Statement geben der
Hintergrund ist dass präsidentinenz
gegessen hier ein Dekret auf den Weg
gebracht hat wonach auch jetzt in der
Ukraine dieser sogenannte europa-tag ab
sofort am 9 mai gefeiert wird damit ähm
bricht er sozusagen mit der Tradition
Russland dass das der Tag des Sieges
über Nazi Deutschland ist das wird jetzt
in Zukunft hier in der Ukraine mit einem
offiziellen Feiertag am Montag gefeiert
und ja das ist also dieser symbolische
Tag dass das jetzt heute hier das erste
Mal gefeiert wird der Europatag ähnlich
wie in vielen anderen europäischen
Ländern auch oder von der Leyen wird ja
auch noch mal gegen Mittag nehmen wir an
bekräftigen dass die Unterstützung der
Europäischen Union gegenüber der Ukraine
unterschütterlich ist und damit ist halt
wie gesagt ein ganz klares Gegenprogramm
zu dem was heute in Russland passiert
hier ähm eingeplant wann immer in der
Vergangenheit sich Präsident selenski
mit westlichen
Staatsoberhaupt dann oder auch
westlichen Partnern getroffen hat ging
es auch meistens um Waffenlieferungen
ist das heute auch geplant wird das
Thema werden was steht auf dem Programm
für die beiden
also wir wissen natürlich immer nicht
ganz genau was dann im Detail alles
besprochen wird aber wir wissen
zumindest dass die Gespräche sich mit
Munitionsnachschub auseinandersetzen
sollen die Europäische Union hat ja
gerade erst am Freitag noch mal neuem
munitionslieferungen oder
Munitionsnachschub im Wert von einer
Milliarde Euro zugesagt das ist auch
wichtig für die Ukraine die ja angeblich
jetzt gerade vor einer Offensive steht
einer früher als Offensive einer
Gegenoffensive und dafür braucht sie
eben vor allem auch nachhaltig und
sozusagen über einen längeren Zeitraum
gesicherten munitionsnachschule in den
letzten Tagen insbesondere gestern hat
es also wieder heftige Luftangriffe
gegeben auch in Kiew du warst selbst vor
Ort kannst du uns berichten wie der
gestrige Tag verlaufen ist und wie die
Lage heute ist also man kennt die
Ukraine ja eigentlich dass sie innerhalb
kürzester Zeit auch schon wieder
aufräumen aber ist es nach so massiven
luftanschlägen überhaupt möglich aktuell
naja das Gute ist ja dass die
ukrainische Luftabwehr mittlerweile
relativ gut funktioniert das heißt ja es
sind vom Sonntag auf Montag also zu
gestern ist eine größere Angriffswelle
auf die Ukraine niedergegangen in
verschiedenen Regionen da sind weit über
100 Raketen und Drohnen unterwegs
gewesen allein 30 sind hier in Richtung
Kiew unterwegs gewesen aber laut Vitali
Klitschko dem Bürgermeister von Kiew
sind eben alle abgeschossen abgefangen
worden das einzige was dann eben im
größeren Ziel passiert ist ist das
Trümmerteile runtergefallen sind und
dass diese dann eben Wohnhäuser
beschädigt haben und auch Verletzte zu
verletzten geführt haben aber du hast es
ganz richtig gesagt die Ukraine sind
natürlich dann im ersten Moment erstmal
sehr geschockt wir haben auch Tränen bei
dem betroffenen Menschen gesehen das ist
wie gesagt auch Terror gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung hier aber ähm ich gehe
davon aus dass dann eben auch schnell
umgeschaltet wird und dass die Ukraine
anfangen die Schäden zu beheben und
aufzur haben und dann ja war es
natürlich relativ bezeichnet das
ausgerechnet in der Nacht zu zum 8 mai
also dem Tag der katholiker Kapitulation
Nazideutschland eine Welle auf die
Ukraine niedergegangen ist viele hatten
dann befürchtet dass es in der Nacht zum
9 mai wo die der Tag ja in Russland
begangen wird noch einmal weitergeht und
das war auch tatsächlich so wir hatten
hier in der Nacht wieder eine
Angriffswelle von denen wieder viele
abgefangen worden sind aber die
Explosionen dieses dieser abfangen
Manöver sozusagen waren hier auch in
unserem Hotel deutlich zu hören er ist
auch gerade die Zerstörung in Bildern
gesehen als du gesprochen hast ganz zum
Schluss noch die Frage wir haben jetzt
auch viel natürlich über die russische
Seite und sich gesprochen aber wie läuft
es mit der geplanten ukrainischen
Offensive und mit der ukrainischen
Fortschreibung dieses Krieges wenn uns
da zum Schluss noch mal die Einschätzung
gibst das wäre super
ja also über diese Gegenoffensive der
von ukrainischer Seite aus wird ja nur
mittlerweile seit Tagen seit Wochen
spekuliert es gibt Experten die sagen
die hat im Grunde in verschiedenen
Phasen schon begonnen es gibt andere die
sagen das kann noch weit bis in den
Herbst dauern
klar ist dass die ukrainische Führung
sagt dass sie mittlerweile über 1500
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge bekommen haben über
230 Kampfpanzer dass die Vorbereitung
für eine solche Offensive ganz offenbar
schon zu fast 100% abgeschlossen sind
der ukrainische Vize
Verteidigungsminister hat gestern in
einem Interview gesagt dass diese
Offensive Panik auf russischer Seite
verursachen werde das ist natürlich auch
das viel Propaganda mit dabei und er hat
gesagt dass sie womöglich im Mai oder
Juni beginnen kannte und genau über
diesen beginnen dann der tatsächlichen
der tatsächlichen Vorstufe von
ukrainischen Truppen wird halt sehr
spekuliert dann wissen wir einfach noch
nicht genau wann ein solcher
losgeht und auch wie er losgeht also ob
das ein großer eine große Bewegung wird
oder ob das eher viele kleinere werden
und vor allem auch wo diese Offensive
stattfinden wird es ist so dass
wahrscheinlich ein Vorstoß vermutet wird
in Richtung meditopol das ist eine
Hafenstadt und wenn dieser gelingen
würde dann wäre eben die Landverbindung
zwischen der Krim und Russland
unterbrochen das wäre ein großer
militärischer Sieg für die Ukraine und
würden auch die Verhältnisse in diesem
Krieg sehr verändern denke ich was wir
im Moment auf jeden Fall sehen ist dass
die Ukraine mit gezielten Angriffen ins
Hinterland der russischen Front bereits
versucht diese Offensive vorzubereiten
also da werden
Munitionsdepots Treibhaus
Treibstoffdepots zerstört der werden
sozusagen die Nachschublinien getroffen
und damit soll diese Front die russische
Front Herr mürbt werden von hinten
sozusagen und das ist durchaus ein
Zeichen dafür dass es bald losgehen
könnte aber wie gesagt wann ist wirklich
so weit ist und ob diese
Offensive jetzt in den nächsten Wochen
oder vielleicht doch erst im Herbst
kommt das kann keiner sagen vor allem
auch weil eine solche Offensive vom
Wetter abhängig ist das hat jemand sehr
viel geregnet gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
können in einem solchen weichenboden
nicht gut operieren also vielleicht
wartet Ukraine indische Seite auch
einfach auf eine Wetter Besserung
Einschätzungen live aus Kia von Tim
Krüger vielen Dank
Tim Krüger wird für uns den Besuch von
Ursula von der Leyen in Kiew heute den
ganzen Tag über begleiten Ihr seid da
natürlich immer live informiert bei ZDF
heute Putin hat nach seiner
Militärparade die noch läuft geplant
einen Kranz niederzulegen am Grab des
unbekannten Soldaten und auch hierzu
natürlich jederzeit live Informationen
immer bei uns online bei ZDF heute bis
hierhin erstmal danke dass ihr dabei
wart für eure Aufmerksamkeit und bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss